my name is Isaac palow check me out on
the bootle Kev
podcast yo bootle cev podcast man
special guest in here my guy Isaac poo
is in the building welcome welcome
welcome thanks for having me for people
who don't know uh this guy is an
incredible artist incredible painter uh
you've seen his works if you are fan of
Griselda uh would you say that you're
cuz you have like a signature style it's
like it would is it is it realism with
your own
twist cuz I don't I know that there's
like you know words for certain styles
of painting well the foundation of my
work is definitely realism it's uh
figurative
um but in the last like I don't know
four or five years of an introducing
more Street contemporary modern
stuff towards you know mixing it with
the realism um like you'll have like a
real like like some realism and then
like the the smiley face yeah yeah yeah
that's part of like you know that's a
spin of contemporary mixing with the
classical realism that I do I do a lot
of
uh Renaissance type of imagery or
religious iconography and I'll mix that
with some Street [__] you know it's
mixing it with maybe some spray paint um
oil p was kind of introducing a new
element to it giving some layer depth
and texture uh that's that's been in
recent years though but the foundation
of my work is is definitely realism how
long have you like been a full-time
artist I would say
since since the beginning of 2020 that's
that's when you were like all in yeah
there was there was you you making money
before 2020 though yeah for sure but it
2020 was like that was the pivoting
moment that's when things really cracked
off was that uh cuz cuz obviously for
people who don't know you uh if you have
seen any of these paintings that you've
done mhm there's like the third eye and
yeah that's kind of like a signature
Isaac thing right and and uh we were
just talking you just dropped the Tupac
print uh how long ago did you do that
painting I did that painting January of
2017 that was that was the first piece
that I did uh incorporating a third eye
kind of like started I ended up doing a
whole series based off of it because it
became really popular and then um so I
did a whole show a whole body of work
surrounding that didn't think it was
going to take off as much as it did but
um you know when Wes picked up the the
concept it really blew up weside gun for
people who don't know yeah yeah so
weside gun saw that painting and then
just contacted you and I you know he's
got this this condo in in Phoenix that's
just like a little art Museum it's got
so many of your pieces in it yeah and
I've been to Buffalo to the store and
your stuff's in there yeah he's got a
gang of my [__] for sure how many
paintings has he got off
you uh probably north of 30 now damn
yeah he's probably he's got a lot he's
got a few sculptures couple of small
pieces ton of prints for you like uh you
know H like I feel like when you have
when you do something like the third
eyye thing you didn't know obviously
that it was going to change change
things for you no not at all it it's
funny cuz I get I talk about that
situation quite a bit and still to this
day I I had no idea I was just I I so
the story the way it goes is I was in
college in in uh Vegas and I dropped out
would you go to UNLV yeah I was going to
UNLV I was technically studying art but
you know I lived right by UNLV their art
programs are ass so I looked off of a
damn like right by the Blueberry Hill
restaurant off a tri
okay I was on no that was on Flamingo it
was on Flamingo and um it was over there
somewhere but shout out to Vegas you're
you're uh more like Northern you're like
more Northern right more Northeast I was
no I was like right behind UNLV so I was
like Flamingo like right by Blueberry
Hill that restaurant that's like I was I
was I was living in South though like
like Moore Henderson I lived on uh
Eastern and Sunset okay yeah yeah right
across the street from mcar Molly M's
old house yeah when it was McCarron I
think they call it something else now I
think it's still McCarron no cuz I try
to look it up really and it's like some
other name yeah it's just stupid so you
were going to school for art which is a
weird thing I feel like when people say
I go to school for art I'm like really I
was majoring in Fine Art but when I got
there I quickly realized that their art
programs aren't really [__] you know
they got feel like a
hustle not not a purposeful Hustle but
there certain people when they say that
they like this is their major I'm like I
mean do you want to be an artist cuz are
they going to teach you how to be like
like I might teach you like technique or
like history or something but like I
feel like you either got the sauce or
you don't yeah I you know I I I wasn't
even planning on going to school I
wanted to go to Pasadena Art Center
that's where most people aspire to go to
when they want to learn you know more
contemporary stuff um kind of further
and expand their Horizons but I went to
please you know my ex's parents my
parents and I was just I just sort of
fell into it I was like all right [__]
it I guess I'm going to go to school you
know I'm school Shut everybody up and
still kind of do what I want got the
little college experience um but you
know when I got to when I when I started
going to school I was already really
proficient in drawing my my portraits
and pencil were already pretty realistic
and I already had a sense of um a
backstory to my work and you know I had
taken art history in high school and I
already I felt like I was
already uh I had already built a solid
foundation as as you know young artist I
already had a style I was already
drawing pretty good i' had already been
exhibiting my work I mean I I started
exhibiting my work when I was 10it so by
the time I was 18 so you already great
at yeah I mean I wouldn't say great I
just already had uh almost a 10year head
start um so I I felt like school was
just kind of unnecessary I already knew
where I what I wanted I already knew
where I was uh for the most part headed
I just figured you know [__] it maybe
I'll no no maybe I'll learn the business
side of it I should have studied uh
business um management or maybe even you
know theater cuz you know I was doing
acting too so I probably would have
benefited more from that but yeah I was
there for about 2 years I dropped out
and when I dropped out I started
painting I I wasn't painting up until
yeah cuz that's I always you'll see see
people who are really good at drawing
and then they end up getting into
painting or tattooing yeah and I'm
always like yo that feels like such a
far thing to be good at that and then
like cuz it's different tools like yeah
it's a different way of making art
that's for sure um but you know my dad's
a a pretty uh well-known artist too in
in the LA community and his work is some
of the real the most incredible pencil
realism I've seen I would I would argue
he's one of the best artist that I've
ever seen yeah um so by the time I was
18 I was already drawing pretty close to
that that level where we would exhibit
our work together side by side and
people would mistake my work for his
work and I would kind of fall into the
shadows and so I already knew then that
I wanted to Veer off and do you know
something different that made me stand
out so that I had my own identity and
then painting seemed like the right fit
and and luckily
it you know I did because it was the
right fit it was able to create big work
uh work that people responded to people
it's so hard to sell pencil drawings
people respond more to paintings the the
texture no for sure I feel like if
someone's going to spend money on
something spend money on a painting
there there aren't pencil drawings that
you know are um as coveted as paintings
are you know if you look at the history
of of the auction houses and all the
pieces of Art that is ever sold for the
most amount of money it's all paintings
it's all paintings or sculptures right
it drawings they they fall short of it
you know there's some drawings I mean if
you're [__] Da Vinci and you got like
one yeah if you're if you're that name
and you're hey